good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight the president is rallying
supporters as we speak in Colorado
Springs were monitoring his remarks for
breaking news we'll go there if it
occurs but for now here's the question
what can you buy with four hundred and
sixty million dollars well of course you
could buy a lot of things you could buy
a Boeing 747 if you wanted one you could
build an entire NFL stadium you could
get a pack of peanut M&Ms for every
single person in this country or you
could take all that money and use it to
get humiliated by Elizabeth Warren on
national television and that's what
Michael Bloomberg did last night maybe
on some level he enjoyed it we don't
want to speculate here though Bloomberg
wouldn't be the first rich liberal with
unusual personal tastes
but either way Warren was happy to play
along you probably already seen the
clips already but this is one of those
exchanges were three playing again and
again and again
Elizabeth Warren just spanked him like
the bad little billionaire he is
vigorously watch I'd like to talk about
who we're running against a billionaire
who calls women fat broads and
horse-faced lesbians and no I'm not
talking about Donald Trump I'm talking
about Mayor Bloomberg are not going to
win if we have a nominee who has a
history of hiding his tax returns of
harassing women and of supporting racist
policies Democrats take a huge risk if
we just substitute one arrogant
billionaire for another you wonder how
often Bloomberg pays to get yelled at
like that pretty expensive role playing
at one point mistress Elizabeth even
forced Bloomberg to admit he wouldn't
allow a strange female employees to
speak honestly about their time working
for him
watch he has gotten some number of women
dozens who knows to sign non-disclosure
agreements both for sexual harassment
and for gender discrimination in the
workplace
so mr. mayor are you willing to release
all of those women from those
non-disclosure agreements so we can hear
their side of the story
if they wish now to speak out and tell
their side of the story about what it is
they allege that's now okay with you
you're releasing them on television
tonight senator Pell holy smokes
makes you wonder about Elizabeth
Warren's husband back home everyone she
revealed that she was the one who asked
for his hand in marriage he said yes of
course it was an offer he couldn't
refuse in the face of a woman like that
Mike Bloomberg just crumbled suddenly
didn't look like one of the world's
richest men he looked old and weak worn
rattled him so completely Bloomberg
could barely function he couldn't
explain his own candidacy he made
apologies for his record at one point
Bloomberg bragged about cutting New York
City's crime rate in half and then
almost instantly disavowed the policy
that made it possible well if I go back
and look at my time in office the one
thing that I'm really worried about
embarrassed about was how it turned out
with stop and frisk how bad was it well
even on the most obvious question the
one he had to know was coming how can
someone as rich as you relate to normal
voters Bloomberg wifted apparently the
army of consultants he's hired to write
his lines forgot to prepare him for it
lady Bloomberg just got sick of being
self-deprecating and decided to revert
to his real personality which is grating
and pompous either way his answer
sounded suspiciously like boasting
because when you're as spectacularly
successful as Michael Bloomberg is April
15th isn't like most people's April 15th
you don't use TurboTax fortunately I
make a lot of money and we do business
all around the world and we are
preparing it in the number of pages will
probably be thousands of pages I can't
go to TurboTax oh but it didn't get
better from there the conversation then
turned to China now Bloomberg knows a
lot about Chinese beginning rich there
and defending its fascist government for
many years he censored his own news
organization to protect that country's
corrupt leadership last night not
surprisingly he was still acting like
China's publicist when asked about
China's carbon emissions the largest in
the world
by far bloomberg claimed that India was
quote a bigger problem which is a total
crock you've got Google check it
yourself
China emits 29% of the world's carbon
twice as much as here in the US and that
number is still rising not falling India
the bigger problem
accounts for just seven percent of the
world's carbon emissions yeah but
Bloomberg's Chinese masters are no doubt
pleased by the lie he told on their
behalf by the end of the night Bloomberg
had failed so completely so utterly that
his odds of winning the Democratic
nomination dropped by a third on the
betting site predicted even the analysts
on cable news many of whom secretly
hoped to work for Michael Bloomberg one
day had to admit his performance was
world historic awful really a new low in
the history of spoken English Gloria
Borger what's the big headline Bloomberg
was awful this was a disaster
for Bloomberg they tore the skin off him
yesterday last night in Las Vegas I
thought was a very bad night for him
he's probably doubling the salaries of
his staff who want to go into the spin
room because I wouldn't want to go in
there and defend him after the night
that he had it was a devastating
introduction to Mike Bloomberg for Mike
Bloomberg to a lot of America Bloomberg
went in as the Titanic billion dollar
machine Titanic Titanic meat iceberg
Elizabeth Warren there's no question
that she could go toe-to-toe with Trump
she left Bloomberg in a puddle on that
debate stage all true for once
Bloomberg ate it last night but here's
the question does it actually matter
that's what's we're thinking about and
the answer is it doesn't really matter
Bloomberg hurt him but she didn't help
herself much not a single person
watching last night wants to listen to
her for the next four years gosh
meanwhile Bloomberg is still enormously
rich and he's still blanketing daytime
television with his ads far more
Americans will see Bloomberg's
commercials than watched last night's
debate that's just the truth of it so
for all the highly entertaining moments
the debate didn't really change the race
Bernie Sanders is still the front-runner
this morning hard as that is to believe
and if anything Sanders is becoming less
impressive as he rises in the polls last
night for example Sanders laid lamely
tried to claim that his
famously aggressive online supporters
the one who are supposedly harassing
opponents on Twitter might actually be
secret Russian agents trying to sow
discord in the Democratic Party hmmmm
Sanders said that on stage unfortunate
people riding the bait were too dumb to
notice it so nobody has to follow up
question and we're all the poorer for
that meanwhile the various Democratic
also-ran spent their evenings savaging
each other boy did they Amy Klobuchar
who's supposed to be Midwestern and nice
took a ball-peen hammer to Lego
candidate Pete Buddha judge watch this
you're staking your candidacy on your
Washington experience you're on the
committee that oversees border security
you're on the committee that does trade
you're literally in part of the
committee that's overseeing these things
and we're not able to speak to literally
the first thing about the politics of
the country to ourselves are you trying
to say that I'm dumb or are you mocking
me here people I wish everyone as was as
perfect as you P but let me tell you
what it's like to be in the arena I'm
actually so proud of the work I've done
on immigration reform and you know what
you have not been in the arena doing
that work you've memorized a bunch of
talking points and a bunch of things Wow
so that was real she clearly hates him
and good for her by the way he's awful
he's the fakest guy in the race not that
it matters neither one of them is going
anywhere in the end by the end of the
night things got so fractious on stage
they couldn't even agree to unite behind
the candidate who got the most votes
think about that for a minute these are
the same people who are always lecturing
you about how the electoral college is
racist and all that matters is the
popular vote but of course they never
meant that look person who means it is
Bernie Sanders and the only reason he
means it is because in this case he's
the only one who can benefit from that
standard at this point it's hard to see
how anybody gets the majority of
Democratic primary votes but Sanders is
so likely to have the most at the end so
in a typical year that would make
Sanders the Democratic nominee but
that's not the case this year so who
wins
who's the nominee that's something our
friends the Democratic Party are going
to have to figure out at their
convention in
key four months from now and good luck
with that